greetings from podcastville it's monday
january 25th uncle joey's joint is
brought to you by
draftkings guess what [__]
the golden tickets are here you're ready
for the super bowl we got [__]
whatever happened yesterday happened
yesterday now we got our [__] players
everybody's ready the teams are in
february [__] seventh
draftkings is the official partner of
super bowl 55
and is bringing back their golden ticket
giveaway with up to 55 million dollars
in prizes that's 55 million bucks with
your name on each one of you [__]
you want to get in on the action all you
got to do is at the draftking super bowl
prediction challenge
and here's the best part they're going
to give you a chance to instantly
instantly win as soon as you submit your
picks
up to 20 dollars that's a lot of
[__] gidas we're talking about
and if you guess right you got a chance
to win a million [__] dollars but
guess what
all that starts tonight you got college
basketball
you got nba basketball you got [__]
hockey
you got college basketball you got
chinese ping pong
this is the season to be [__] jolly
do you understand me
download the draftking sportsbook app
right now
use promo code joey to enter the free
55 million dollar
super bowl prediction chat can you
imagine if you hit this and the [__]
mega lotto
don't be sucking your dick like that
chinese guy from the united airlines
you never heard from him again did you
know that'll be you
on an island get your dicks up your
balls fanned
you and the draft king sports book app
use
promo code joey everybody gets an
instant prize
up to 25 000 just for playing
you got nothing to [__] lose so use
your promo code joey now
and enter the 55 million dollar
super bowl challenge only at draftkings
the official daily fantasy partner of
super bowl
55. terms and conditions and eligibility
restrictions applied
see draftkings.com for details and don't
forget
to download the app and press in joey
now
you got to be over 21 and
you got to live in the areas where they
gamble colorado tennessee
this is what the lawyers make me [__]
say all right so
if you got a problem with gambling we
don't want sean here
go take care of your problem go get a
skateboard go take one of those [__]
pills that doesn't let you
gamble and come back but if you're ready
to rock
[__] draftkings sportsbook app is
ready for you right now
download it press code joey and enter
the 55 million dollar super bowl
prediction challenge that's
draftkings.com
joey the joint is also brought to you by
onyx
one of my all-time favorites and now
they're introducing
these protein powder puffs korean
barbecue
spicy cheddar 15 grams per [__] bag
where are you gonna get that from
you gotta eat two eggs to get that [__]
you understand me not to mention
melatonin which is helping people sleep
and one of the vitamins that helps
against covid
you still got [__] alpha brain
and you still got new mood and shroom
tech i mean what don't they have you
covered what
what the [__] have they done for you not
to go to honor.com right now go to
honor.com right now
take a look at the great selection of
supplements they have and get back to me
[__]
but it all starts by you going to
honor.com right now
click on the supplements whether it's
the protein powder
the shroom tech these new protein power
puffs that are [__] delicious
that's what i ate during the fight
saturday night i was hungry a little
late night quarter to one
a little apple maybe a little protein
puff
they also have the little let me taste
them they have some peanut butter
chocolate
protein [__] bites that are
tremendous also listen
when it comes to honor they're the best
that's why i do business with them
go to honor.com right now and press in
church
and get 10 off of any of their
supplements delivered right to your
[__] kaza
who's better than me nobody who's better
than you
nobody on a monday morning the joint is
also brought to you by
cbd lion why haven't i got hooked on
pain pills why
because cbd lion has helped me through
this [__] surgery
with the the roll on the gummy bears
the the tinctures and also the
just a regular they have a like a like a
an ointment that i use also i've been
going around this
for for two weeks with this cbd line and
now is when i realized how potent
and how good their product is the cbd
lion did their [__] homework
they're like the rest of these companies
that put some [__] sugar in water
and you're jumping up and down i feel
great no you don't stop lying to your
[__] friends
i feel good right now and i just had 2
000 [__] staples put in my leg you
understand me
i don't even take those pills to a
[__] late night so i don't wake up
but
part of my pain management is cbd lion
go to cbdlion.com right now
take a look at their third-party lab
results learn about cbd
cbn and how can how they can make an
advantage in your [__] life
go to cbd line right now press in
joey church whatever the [__] you want
and get 20
off delivered right to your [__] crib
let's get this [__] party started
enough
with the chitter chatter joey it's
monday morning
we got [__] to talk about people to see
and things to do
enjoy
hey how you doing
hey look who it is
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here monday morning
january 25th a beautiful
[__] day to be alive we're doing this
podcast and i got a couple things to do
today i got the stitches taken out and i
got physical therapy
the leg has been feeling great thank you
for all the well wishes
uh it's been two weeks and
it's [__] great thanks to cbd lion
i'm not [__] up on the pain pills i
must have called my buddy timmy who
knows all about them 10 times
to ask them not to get hooked and it all
worked itself out
i got more than plenty in there i've
been alternating with the aspirin
and the ice and the tens machine and
the only time you really don't want pain
is at night when i go to sleep
i don't want to be like i got woken up
by pain two or three times at night it
wasn't good
so that's the only time i want to be
covered you really can't take it my
sleep gets [__] up when you eat those
pain pills too so
i had to work around so now i take him
like a nine
and i drink my [__] tea at like 11 so
i go down at [__] midnight 12 30. but
what do you guys give a [__]
i'm just here telling you about my
weekend for starters let's talk about
what we witnessed on saturday night
what happened the decline and my take on
it
let's start from the beginning number
one i've always loved conor mcgregor i
thought conor mcgregor was a great
fighter
i thought his [__] footwork was
phenomenal i thought his range
is masterful the guy before that who
his range worked the range similar to
that was anderson silva
i made a comment one time the only
disagreement
i had with conor mcgregor was i did not
like the dennis eva fight
i thought they should have gave him a
better opponent because i knew it would
have come back to bite him in the ass
and number two i didn't like how he was
treated because
i've been there i've been there as a
comic where
you know you're in a room with six
comics and one comic gets like a [__]
a mansion and you and the other six guys
gotta split a [__] floor
so my my whole thing was i didn't like
the treatment of him or whatever but
he does generate a lot of cash so i get
it
from that perspective but from being
there
i didn't like it but i've always thought
he was great
i always thought he was a superb fighter
he did things that nobody else
did in the sport you know he was a
two-time [__] champion
now you gotta ask yourself what happened
me
i love to be an observer i've always
been an observer
you look at things you shut your [__]
mouth
and you see what happens and what goes
down on that
i can tell you one thing for sure about
me
when i started watching mma and i was
friends with rogan
way before like i didn't get into mma
until maybe after i was friends with
those guys for 10 years
i didn't want to see two guys wrestle
with [__] bikinis on and
you know i came from the bruce lee
school i turned on the ufc one day and i
saw a butter bean
you know a guy's got a body like mine
he's in the ring fighting
i would i thought this was just like a
[__] joke and then i actually
saw anderson silva in his uh first fight
against chris levin
and i was blown the [__] away i became a
fan
i also watched the ultimate fighter
finale and i had become a fan there's
nothing to do with rogan
rogan and those guys were in they would
be sitting in the car talking about jiu
jitsu all the time
i didn't give a [__] i was looking out
the window like rain man stoned to the
gills
thinking to myself what are these
[__] [__] talking about sweeps
and [__]
arm bars and [__] but once i watched the
ufc i really started
comparing mma to stand-up
i started looking at my career and what
my strengths and weaknesses were
in the mma you have jujitsu you have
wrestling
you have boxing and you have kickboxing
and you have to combine them and you
have to see how they come at you from
all angles
while in stand-up you have storytelling
you have improv and you have the
straight traditional stand-up setup
so i was always very very good at
improv i started improving not in an
improv
troupe i started on stage improving by
myself
because in boulder every week i had the
same [__] mutts
eating the same [__] steak special
and you had to give them new jokes every
week i couldn't
i wasn't that good in the beginning so i
have to just
improvise so i got really good at
improvising
and today i'm still very good at
there's only one problem with
improvising that it's either everything
or nothing you either go 100
i either look like a [__] god that's
floating up there
or i eat a bag of [__] the third week at
uncle vinnie's when i came back i ate a
bag of [__]
because i relied on my improvising i
gave up on my [__]
storytelling and i gave up on my
traditional setup punchline routine
so punch uh comedy and mma are very much
connected
because they're in art there's a hundred
ways to do an armbar
if you walk into three different jiu
jitsu schools you'll notice
that each one will give you a different
detail that one didn't give you
because it's an art there's 30 ways to
[__] do a kimora there's 30 ways to
do an armbar
there's 30 ways to make somebody laugh
so i'm a fan of
mma because it made me a stronger
stand-up comedian
when i saw conor mcgregor i thought he
had all the tools he was great
they hyped them up
the dentist receiver fight pissed me off
and i became vocal about it and people
took it the wrong way like if i was a
i didn't like conor mcgregor and that
wasn't the case
you guys know i'm not a hater i give
props
even when i don't like certain people i
may not be a big fan of somebody
musically
but i give them props you know i saw
jerry cans grant
cantrell once at the roosevelt hotel
i said hello the guy looked at me like i
was [__]
like i had aids and cobit i could tell
he wasn't that nice of a person
i asked around people were like you got
to stay away from him
he doesn't even do certain radio
interviews you understand me it's not
now
do i not listen to [__] jaw flies
dirt you know the other one with the dog
on the cover do
do i not listen to them yeah like [__]
rotten apple
and and nutshell there's no better
guitar playing
but i just jerry can't draw i'm not a
fan of because of his personality but
whatever that doesn't
whatever that doesn't uh
that it doesn't [__] affect me in no
way i'm still a fan of his [__]
music i was never never a fan of
mcgregor
i just wasn't a fan of the treatment and
that deniseva fight should have really
been a frankie edgar fight
and frankie edgar was a different
frankie edgar then it would have came
back
let's say he would have lost right he
was still
25 years old he was still making money
and he still could have
in his prime which is 29 30 31
he would have been a phenomenal fighter
if mcgregor would have took two losses
down the line early
he would have been a phenomenal fighter
so he fights dennis eva i forget who he
fights after that
and then they give him all that boxing
[__]
he they give him all that boxing [__]
when he
fought you know mayweather and
that takes away from focus that takes
away
from what you're doing now this made
this made all these ufc fighters jaded
you saw
every time somebody thought if a [__]
janitor fought
he called out conor mcgregor because
it made you jaded towards him as a human
being not because of his actions
listen the thing about khabib and all
that [__]
he threw a thing through the glass
that's all part of the game
there's everything is fair and loving
war you got right all's fan loving war
so what are you guys talking about
it starts with a psychological when
you're fighting somebody
mcgregor used to use the psychological
he'd start with the psychological attack
on you
and then he'd break you down with the
psychological when you got into the ring
against them
with the lights and everything else you
immediately changed you couldn't think
it was
it was a statue in front of you that you
could not [__]
beat you know uh when he beat eddie
alvarez in the garden
i was very much in shock to fashion how
he beat him
now today i mean every eddie alvarez
isn't the fighter he was then
but when it came to dustin poirier
dustin poirier what did dustin poirier
do after conor mcgregor beat him up
he got stronger he went into the gym and
he fought twice as hard
and he kept fighting people one by one
by one okay
he lost to khabib too khabib is super
[__] human
but the difference between connor and
dustin
was exactly what conor said inactivity
the inactivity right now i'm a stand-up
comic for seven months i didn't get on
stage
when i go to get back on stage i can't
tell you guys to pay me all this [__]
money
to give me 50 [__] bucks i'm not
worth 50 [__] bucks
why because it's inactivity now there's
a pandemic going on
i can't get on stage nobody else could
get on stage so we're all going through
the same thing
yeah people do certain shows here and
there but you're not getting on stage on
the amount
and the frequency you were getting on
stage before this pandemic
so we all suffered if there was no
pandemic going on
i'm out there because as a stand-up
as a basketball player as a comedian as
a fighter
this is how you're always thinking
you're always saying [__]
right now my opponent is doing something
when i played basketball when i was a
kid when i was in the seventh grade
i'd be out there at seven o'clock ten
o'clock at night playing
because i knew that the guys i was gonna
play against weren't doing that
that's my thinking when you're a
stand-up comic when you're a basketball
player i remember talking to dan my rare
and having this conversation as a kid
that from basketball i took one thing
that i have to assume that that other
guy is practicing right now
that school we're playing against
they're all together right now playing
in the backyard
they're probably not they're probably
not they're probably relying
on their [__] talent but a guy like
me had to work hard
when it came to stand up so i had to get
on stage multiple times at night
two three times working out a joke boom
take it to the next place try that joke
again oh it didn't work
because i didn't set it up right it
takes work
and it takes activity it takes a lot of
activity while mcgregor was sitting
there
saying no and yes and thinking about
this and thinking about that
somebody was training and that person
was dustin poirier
that person was charles aloe vera that
person was
old kukui that person was just engaging
so right now what what is mcgregor's
next step and i love conor mcgregor he's
got all the talent to pull it off
remember you don't know what you did
wrong because you're on the canvas
when i did uh that that [__] special
socially unacceptable
we did two [__] shoots of it the
first time i went up there and shot
i ate a bag of dog [__] because who was
i trying to be
again john mulaney i couldn't be john
mulaney
if i [__] wanted to you understand me
john mulaney is john mulaney and joey
diaz is joey diaz
i tried to be john mulaney i switched it
all around i went up there and i told
the story about a guy with a big dick
i loosened them up a little bit i became
joe diaz i sucked them in
and then i attacked i learned that from
experience from getting knocked down the
first time
what did i do not to get the laughs i
deserved okay
fine i got i went over that and then
after that i got a lot better
i knew what it was to become joe diaz
you're going to go to an audition one
day you're going to come to me and go
joy
what do i do here you're going to hear
these words constantly be yourself
when you're sitting there going but you
i am myself be yourself
be yourself be yourself what does that
mean they're looking for you
they're looking for what you bring to
the [__] table
so every time i go up on stage and i
bomb i don't know if you guys watch the
clip this week
of uh josh wolfe and uh bill burr
talking about when brody and joey diaz
bomb they bombed when i bombed
i'm here to tell you i bombed but i
bombed with grace
because i've never told the audience how
you [__] suck
what's wrong with you people tonight
what does this take to stick out of your
ass
no some comics bomb and they blame it on
the audience
some comics bomb and they blame it on
the acoustics of the [__] room
some old comics bomb and they blame it
on
the drunk lady in row 52 no
whenever you bomb you blame it on your
[__] self i know i do
whenever i bomb i walk off that stage
there's a little grin on my face
part of me is breaking i'm walking like
[__] saint lazarus
part of me is breaking but the other
part i'm trying to keep my composure
on the way home i i know i know the
answer why i bumped
i came out too cocky i did this i didn't
use this joke
i set this joke up i insulted this guy
wrong these are the things you learn
by doing but in activity it's like a
[__] stand-up
it's like when somebody comes up to me
and says i'm gonna do [__] stand up
i'm just waiting
for right five minutes when i walk away
i'm like good luck
i'm not trying to be a scumbag or
negative
i know that you're approaching it the
wrong way i don't want you to write five
minutes
i just want you to get on stage and get
it over with the quicker you get on
stage the quicker you get this disaster
over it
it's like people i'm gonna lose weight
and join jiu jitsu hello
what do you [__] join jiu jitsu for
to lose weight you're never gonna lose
that 30 pounds to join jiu jitsu
just go to [__] jiu jitsu and do it
inactivity
is [__] horrible you know the last
10 months the first six months of this
[__] thing i couldn't write
it wasn't it was an activity i would go
to write my journal in the morning i
would finish it
but when i'd read it back and be talking
about sushi
and [__] uh the mars and the kennedy
assassination
my mind was all over the place i wasn't
zoomed in
i wasn't [__] focused now i'm focused
you know when i first started going to
uncle vinnie's i was dying to slow down
i would have to come back here at night
and [__] stay up and
write a little bit and adjust this joke
and listen to this one and
oh that joke is [__] horrible you
have to be very honest with yourself
so when kind of hit the [__] mat
against nate diaz
when kind of got choked out against nate
diaz my life would have changed
if i was kind i'm already making a
million [__] dollars
what's the biggest investment i can make
the investment that you're making
yourself
i would have hired vinnie magelise off
the radar to sign a
a contract that nobody would know that
vinnie mangaly should be training me
with my [__] jiu jitsu he's one of
the best in the [__] world
i would have the best boxing trainer
available to me
you know i would pull what gsp did gsp
wasn't the champion
because he sat at home and fanned his
balls you know when i saw gsp
on the [__] gymnastic rings looking
like [__] jesus and nazareth
getting hung upside down i'm like this
guy is a fighter
but he's doing gymnastics this guy is
exploring his body in ways that nobody
else has
he's taken the money he's he's making
and he's investing in the number one
investment you could ever do
yourself so you know when kind of lost
against nate diaz when he got choked
right there my game would have changed
we all rely on that one [__] thing
yeah listen if i'm bombing all i got to
do is
slow it down a little bit and go into a
story that you've already [__] heard
i could change it around i could add it
that's what i usually that was my go-to
you know if you're bombing you could
always go to a story
i didn't want to be that guy i wanted to
be able to switch it up if i'm bombing
get my composure back put my opponent in
my guard
it's putting your opponent back in your
guard and go back to the basics
grab the sleeve push them towards you
with your knees
it's the same thing over and over and
over nothing happens
so if my [__] storytelling isn't
working
i pull you back into my guard and we
start from scratch that's why i told you
how mma
how jiu-jitsu and stand-up are the
[__] same
when you start going off the beaten path
you pull the [__] back into your
guard you hold on to his sleeves
and you push them towards you that's
what you pull them towards you and you
try to [__] dissect them from there
go for an arm bar
sweep them whatever the [__] you want to
do it's the same thing with [__]
comedy
connor always dependent on his left hand
you can't just depend on your left hand
you know why because everybody's got
strength in the ufc
chronicle you know when if you watch the
fight against khabib
watch the fourth round watch when
how quickly khabib slips in
for the takedown it is the most
brilliant thing in the world
connor never even saw it i'm not putting
connor down
i'm just telling you that khabib was so
good at that move
that he engaged conor with his hand boom
and after that kyla didn't get back up
he tapped that's the second time he got
choked out
with a rear naked choke i wouldn't mind
if he got a kimora
i wouldn't mind if if if if
khabib would have got him with a
triangle or an arm bar or something
but to get taken down the same way nate
diaz took you down
tells me that you didn't work on that
you didn't work on that [__] move
and again i'm not i'm not here putting
down conor mcgregor i love conor
mcgregor
i'm here thinking to myself if i'm conor
what do i got to do next first of all
here's the problem that you will
there was two key elements in this fight
that i didn't like already off the bat
against dustin poirier
now you're looking at me going big mouth
did you bet it no i didn't bet it i
didn't need to bet it
i'm watching i watched some michael
chandler fight i watch the jessica i
fight
i watch i'm observing i'm learning i'm
trying to learn
this because i want to work closely with
draftkings and i want to help you guys
make money okay we're trying here
all together to do something so i want
you to learn when you look at lines
lines are everything gambling i listen
to two things
somebody asked me during the week who do
you like you like mcconnell or dustin
in my heart i knew that once dustin
fought
connor and he saw what all the hype was
about
that the second time his odds were gonna
get
increase because he had already fought
kabib
he had nothing to lose he fought gazi
he's
fought everybody that he could in that
[__] division
okay so now you're gonna fight conor for
the second time
you're not gonna be scared you know once
you do the garden the first time you're
going to be a little [__] up once you
walk in there the second time
you're not going to be [__] scared at
all so
i i i love dust dustin off of that one
but
i also thought conor was more committed
connor said two things there was two
things that happened during this fight
that i didn't like
number one he said he was running five
businesses
when you're running five businesses your
focus on your main business which is for
me is stand-up
for me is stand-up for him it's fighting
i can't run five businesses right now
can you imagine me trying to run a
consulting business
a podcasting firm like i'm not just in
charge of
uncle joey's joint now i got 20 podcasts
under me
trying to be a dad trying to be a
husband
somewhere along the line it's gonna
[__] slip
somewhere along the line it's not gonna
work out i understand you're trying to
provide for your family or whatnot
but at the end of the day number one the
first thing you are
is a fighter so you gotta focus on
fighting
every [__] day you know i was having
a hard time there
like when i went to shoot the soprano
movie two years ago i had to cancel a
few dates
every day my agent will call me when do
you want to reschedule the dates guess
what i did i stopped talking to the
[__]
i stopped talking to him and my manager
i would not take their calls
i'm focusing on a movie [__] for me to
do the best job i can on this movie
i don't really give a [__] when they
reschedule the texas date
or the utah date or the [__] san
francisco day they're not going anywhere
they're gonna be there forever i focus
on
what's in front of me and that's what
the problem with most people are they
open up a business or something
but they got 90 things going on then the
business fails and they wonder what the
[__] happened
you're trying to cover too much real
estate you're only one person there's
only so many hours in a [__] day
you know right now i'm having a great
time i'm almost finished with my first
chapter
i know it's taken me a little longer
than anticipated i told you from the
beginning i was [__]
but i'm sticking to it because i have
time to write the book now because i
don't have
all these other things in my [__]
life now mercy's back in school
you know [__] i got a little time
there so i make myself hour 15 blocks
and i sit down sometimes the leg lately
hasn't let me sit because it goes right
into the back of my hamstring
and it kind of cuts off circulation
sometimes so i got to
be a little [__] nuts but i'm almost
done with it but i have the time to
include the book now
when i was doing all the podcasting and
the [__] road work and
dealing with industry and auditions i
didn't have the time now
i got nothing but time they ain't gonna
shoot dick to [__] it next year
said do you follow what i'm saying to
you i didn't like that point that he had
five businesses and number two
that they're already talking about
khabib he didn't even beat poirier yet
and they're already talking about an
upcoming fight with well
it could be for what for what let the
kid
fight this is why i tell people to work
with what's in front of you
i don't give do you think i give a [__]
about september right now
do you think i give a frenchman [__]
about august i give a [__] about one
thing
monday january 25th my stitches are
coming out
i got physical therapy and tonight i get
to eat dinner with my family my wife and
i get to write my book that's all i give
a [__] about
february 19th and 20th i had a date for
uncle vinnie
february 19th my birthday to me is like
[__] the year
2025. like i don't even think about it's
got nothing to do with me
i worry about today that's the first
move then i worry about the week
that's the second move then i worry
about the month i try to time everything
out
but i don't try to worry about well i'm
gonna do this
and then i'm gonna do this movie and
then i'm gonna reoccur in there i don't
i don't worry about that [__] that's how
you get [__] up by thinking
i worry about what's in front of me so
right away he hadn't even fought dustin
poirier
and they're already talking to khabib
why khabib already told you
khabib told you khabib is a man's man
khabib
i get a lot from khabib because it's
like when i tell you when it's over
it's over i'm not snorting coke no more
i'm not smoking coke no more
i'm not [__] doing joy karate videos
no more i stop
when i stop i stop there ain't no coming
back
you guys thought that the church was
going to end in some way no
it's over we moved on this is what life
is about
looking back enjoying it something and
going [__] it that was fun to do
but it's time to move the [__] on i
don't want somebody to ask me to leave
i want to leave on my own [__] terms
so right now if i'm [__]
you know last night you saw uh
connor on his back and you saw he was
hurt
and what do you think was on his mind it
doesn't matter i made 10 million
yes that's on his mind that's on my mind
too
he's laughing all the way to the [__]
bank but not really because he's a
he's got the heart of a [__] lion and
he's a [__] tiger
he's on his back thinking to himself
what the [__] happened
i got this [__] dana already talking
to me dana go away
go away you're the kiss of death when
was the last time i saw you fight
not never so please go away i'll call
you when i want to fight to be
let me just focus on dust and [__]
pourier
but they already you know fight dustin
then you're going to get complete you're
going to make
the highest sales of your life and what
happened now you got nothing what are
you in talks with khabib for
khabib told you three months ago he's
not fighting anymore why are you
bothering [__] khabib
why you gave him a million dollars twice
or three million dollars
you know how much [__] three million
dollars gets you in [__] up with
afghanistan wherever the [__] he's from
do you have any [__] idea
he don't really what is he he don't do
drugs he buys a t-shirt from time to
time
he eats a gyro what the [__] do you give
a [__]
no no we're gonna get some people on the
phone and let them know
don't give a [__] khabib already choked
him out and beat up half his [__]
family and his friends
he don't want no part of that no more
why are you doing this to the kid
so the kid can't focus on what's in
front of him so right now
i'm conor mcgregor i'm thinking one
thing that's it
that's it for me to [__] do this i'm
27 years old i still got the world by
the balls
i've got a couple losses but this ends i
put a picture of gus
justin gagey up in my room i put a
picture of elka cooy up in my room
i put a picture of [__] charles aloe
vera up in my room
and i put a picture of [__] dustin
poirier up in my room
and that's my list nate diaz that's over
with already
they don't want to fight he don't want
to fight he's got to fight what's in
front of him
and that's what's in front of him you
guys were jumping up and down
when he beat up a poor [__] busted
cowboy i love cowboy cerrone
big fan of cowboy cerrone great friends
with him
got his number called me a couple months
ago for a movie
listen cowboy cerrone has overserved his
purpose he fought every 90 days
and he got old quick once he had the kid
again another guy that was living
[__] 100 percent
you saw the transformation happen very
quickly
so they gave him an old cerrone who i
[__] love
i love myself a human being i love him
as a man i love him as a fighter
but donald cerrone in his day with a
club at [__]
conor mcgregor that fight was given to
him because they knew he was where he
was at
they can [__] surround 250 thousand
dollars for that [__] fight and kind
of made the rest
but now there's no more that there's no
more nate diaz
there's no more that you got four
[__] people in front of you
you got el kukui okukui okukui's just
coming off a loss
that's your next fight you just came off
a loss
you got out kukui you beat out kukui
you go for justin gagey you beat justin
gagey you gotta fight oliveira
i think oliver is at 155 and if you
fight oliveira
and then we go back to dustin poirier
forget about max holloway forget about
all those
try belts and all that [__] just worry
about
what's in front of you conor mcgregor i
think you're a great [__] fighter
i think you hit hard on a [__]
freight train and i just think that over
time
you lost uh focus of what's
what was in front of you so many people
are coming at you
and bro listen i'm a [__]
[__] heel comic and i
know that what it's like to [__]
having a conversation with mike about
the podcast
and getting a call from somebody because
somebody always wants something
oh they want you to do this and you're
in the middle of something completely
different
i'm in the middle of writing a book and
also somebody calls me oh they're
thinking about you for
cologne and you're like cologne you know
they're thinking about you for
advertising a [__] whiskey
you're like my mind is somewhere else my
mind isn't an octagon
i can't stop what i'm [__] doing what
do you think he you know it was like one
time he [__] didn't come over to do
press
and people attacked him guys i'm in the
middle of [__] training
you want me to get up and take a 24-hour
[__] flight
which depletes three-quarters of my
[__] energy
to go do press to go hear the same
[__] questions
over and over and over and over again
and i understand
there's a lead up to the fight you have
to promote the fight
the fighter has to focus on what he does
fight the comic has to do what he does
best get on stage when you have all this
district you saw a comic
how many times have you seen a comic
that's [__] great
a raw straight up [__] comic
and all of a sudden he gets a tv show
you've been following him since day one
he gets a tv show you're excited about
it
you watch the tv show you order shirts
you tell your friends about it you have
viewing parties
and then you go see a stand-up and it's
[__] a horror show you're like
what the [__] happened you know what
happened
time time is what happened he got smoke
blown up his ass that's what happened
he got so many people coming at him
publicis
managers [__] agents assistants
you got all these people coming at you
blowing smoke up your ass
fake [__] smoke oh that joke about
the chicken
we love it the joke sucks how do i know
who has that happened to
you're looking at them the joke sucks
but they'll tell you whatever the [__]
they want to hear to build your
confidence i appreciate that
but i'd rather you be honest with me and
say joey this ain't working
this ain't working you got to make it
stronger okay then i have to sit down
and write it out every week same thing
with this podcast i was struggling in
the beginning
this podcast that i feel i still feel
like i'm struggling but guess what
i'm gonna keep pushing when this podcast
opportunity came up and i spoke to mike
i had two options i had two [__]
options okay
my first option was to order cameras
drill holes
and wait we would have just gotten the
podcast started right now
if we wanted to do this podcast i wanted
to do this
this podcast would have just got off the
floor by now we would have just got all
the boards
all the wiring we would have just set up
the bar with electricity
and everything would have been helped a
leap except we would have had no [__]
guests
we would have been in the same [__]
boat so
when this opportunity came up i had two
options i could sit here
write stupid jokes go on twitter go on
patreon and keep telling you guys
that the podcast is coming soon the
podcast is
coming soon the podcast is coming soon
and meanwhile
charlie's doing a podcast it may not be
the podcast the best podcast in the
world
but he's in that bush getting stronger
i'm over here getting [__] weaker
telling you i'm gonna do a podcast
do you understand what i'm talking to
you about so i had choices to make even
with this podcast
i came here and sucked dick for [__]
three [__] months
i came here at a [__] ass for three
[__] months with this podcast
i had no direction where it was going i
didn't know where it was going
i hadn't i didn't know right now i still
don't know where the [__] podcast is
going but
i'm sitting down during the week and i'm
focusing on what i need to tell you and
what the message is to get across
so at least we have something to work
with it's not a two three hour podcast
no more
because i'm not a [__] ego what am i
fidel castro i'm gonna sit here for
eight hours embark on [__] orders
how egotistical do you have to be this
gives me enough time just to tell you
what i'm thinking about
to talk a subject to you that's that's
common we're both
have in common about what what we saw on
saturday night
what we both saw on saturday michael
chandler was great
and still my heart goes out to connor
i'm still a [__] fan
and i want him to do this [__] simple
thing for me
and that's to put four pictures up i
think he's the number four
uh rated lightweight in the world well
let's take the number three in front of
you and you're gonna take them down
one by one this would be my plan one by
[__] one
i get the best jiu jitsu instructor i
get that guy from penn state that the
world's greatest wrestler
whatever you need to do and i'd be out
there every day on those [__] mats
working on it your strength are your
hands your hands are your strength
yeah i hit the pad from time to time but
i would focus on the stuff that people
are going to attack now
what's the first thing that happened
last night dustin poirier
took him down in a conor mcgregor style
takedown
and kept him down and kind of got up
okay but now that let connor know he
could take him down
so connor's got to let people know that
he can't be taken down
because now everybody that goes up
against khan is going to do exactly what
khabib did
is take him the [__] down and it's that
simple and that
but with with all that said i'm still a
big kind of fan
i hope he comes out of this victorious i
don't want him to have one belt
i just want him to get the one belt and
prove his point that he is one of the
greatest fighters
that the sport has ever seen but to do
that
he has to [__] focus and
focus is the main thing and it's what's
in front of you
now to get off that we got off that
subject
i want to talk to you about something
else then i'll get you the [__] out of
here
because you learn [__] every week i talk
to mikey you know
i talk to my friends i talk to
i talk to a lot of people about a lot of
different things every week
and one thing that everybody has one
thing that we all share in common
whether we're lgbtq whether you were
[__]
uh we like to eat [__] whether we like
to eat ass
is the gift of the relationship you know
when i was a kid
i was raised catholic and they and i
don't know if you guys know the seven
sacraments it's like
baptism [__] uh
not confirmation uh what's communion
confirmation [__] anointing of the
sick
there's like seven of them you know uh
anyway it doesn't really matter but one
of them one of the sacraments is
marriage
and as a kid i was always like why the
[__] is
marriage a [__] sacrament you know
like i never really [__] thought
about it
okay i'm talking to an audience here
that's between 20 and 32.
you guys have girlfriends you guys have
living girlfriends
some of you guys leon you just live your
life slinging dick over there in [__]
spain i love you to death
uh you know jay bish has a steady wife
you know
bob has a steady wife we all have
different different relationship
issues when i was 20
21 i i didn't know what to expect from
marriage
i knew i wanted to be married i really
did want to be married
but i didn't know what to expect from it
so
august of 85 i met a girl and four years
later we got married
under the weirdest [__] conditions in
the world but we got married
did it work no it didn't work it didn't
work because i had never worked on my
marriage
i am not ashamed to say this i thought
marriage was
you marry a girl you [__] she does
laundry you cook you pay the bills and i
thought that's what a marriage was
if you go into a marriage thinking that
way
it's gonna fail or you're gonna have uh
like not a healthy marriage you know i'm
not a marriage counselor
i'm just telling you what i lived
through you know
so when i first got married i got
married like anybody else i was young
i was stupid i thought i knew what love
was you know i was in love
in the sixth grade obviously it got me
left back
and then when i was 19 20 i fell in love
with another girl that i really
had deep feelings for uh
she wasn't wife material and i wasn't
husband material
and we missed our mark and and that
that really broke my heart my
relationship in 84
with dear friends today today with me
and her dear friends
she lives 20 minutes from me in jersey
we talk once twice a week
uh you know whatever love we we were in
love
we were better friends than we were
lovers of boyfriend and girlfriend
but after my heart got broken in 84 i
did what every other man
does oh i'm not gonna ever get married
again oh i'm never gonna have another
girlfriend again
i'm gonna live my life like charles
bronson you know i grew up on charles
bronson
and clint eastwood and men like that
that
they didn't have women they it was like
a woman was a pest to them
they had a woman but they were sort of
like a pest like a toy
you know and that's what i looked at
women asked when i was 21
to 25 it was i had respect for them
i had respect for women i mean it wasn't
that i was disrespectful
i just didn't really know the games of
marriage
and why they call marriage a gift i know
that on october 15
1991 when that girl came in and told me
she wanted to get separated
i was very happy because i could do
comedy now
i wasn't happy because i couldn't raise
my daughter
but through time another unhappiness
took over my heart
and it was the unhappiness of failing at
marriage
i failed at the most common
thing that we do the gift of
communication i failed
i read guys i don't know how to tell you
this
i cried myself to sleep more between
1993 and 1996
than i did the years after my mother
died and i was 10 years younger
i cried myself to sleep because i wanted
to be a productive member of society i
cried myself to sleep because i wanted
to succeed as a comedian
but the most the tears that came out of
my face the hardest
was the tears of losing my wife and
failing as a husband
because you got to be [__] [__]
to fail as a husband
and i did fail i failed with a [__]
f plus okay and i'll tell you what as
freelance as i am as much like the [__]
around and eat ass and
blow up things it affected me that
divorce affected me because it wasn't
bad enough that i
had a ged it wasn't bad enough that i
went to prison
it wasn't bad enough that i didn't have
a family now it's bad
you failed at a common [__] thing
marriage you just failed guy there's no
two ways of [__] looking at it you
failed at it so
before you go tapping yourself on the
back thinking you're a [__] comedian
you failed at [__] marriage and guys
i it bothered me
it bothered me but i did what
we would do i did what the old joey diaz
would do
i'll never get married again i don't
have to deal with it again
right that's that's what we do naturally
as losers
i'm a loser so that's what i do i don't
deal with it again
i'll never do that again you know it's a
smart thing
and it's what a loser does i'm never
going to get on a horse again no you got
to get on that horse again
no matter what it is get on the horse
whether you want to continue to do it
that's up to you
but you got to figure it out again so
for years
from 91 to whatever my life was a
relationship mess
i had girlfriends and i had girls i
slept with over drugs
that didn't make me feel a lot better
either you know that didn't make me feel
better
i could lie to you when i crack those
jokes they're funny
but just having sex with people and then
going home the next day
and then you see him out and you wave
and that's it
that that that's it that didn't feel
good either
so i knew that it wasn't gonna work but
i was a loser
i couldn't be with a woman because i had
nothing
to bring to the [__] table but
2000 comes along and i meet this [__]
little cute redneck named terry and we
go for coffee
and i looked at the relationship from a
different angle i said if i want this to
work
i have to work it this [__] way i
can't let us go there
i can't let us do this and i worked it
and don't
she'll tell you there was times that for
our first five years
that she had problems with me on the
behavioral level not as being mean to
her or
whatever i just stuck to a plan
because i wanted it to work i had ruined
enough relationships like i said in the
beginning
of even on the church you want me to
help you ruin a relationship
call me if you want to ruin a
relationship hit me up on an email
i'll get you out of there in three days
i'll get i'll get her packing the bags
for you
i'll even get her to give you an advance
to leave
i'm the king of breaking up
relationships
but for once i wanted one to work
and one thing i was with her for a year
then i we were living together for a
year
then came five years then in 2007 i got
cleaned from cocaine
then two years later i thought to myself
what the [__] was i thinking
why haven't i married this girl is it
because of my fear from the first
marriage
yeah it was because i don't think i'm
gonna have to cover the spread
yeah it was well guess what [__] you're
gonna have to cover the spread as a man
so whatever the [__] you're feeling or
doubting you better push that to the
side
and you better marry this girl because
if not you're gonna lose her
and if i lost terry i wouldn't be here
today
without terry i wouldn't be in this
position today because i didn't make
terry my wife
i made terry my partner
i made terry my partner and instead of
not taking her opinions because she
wasn't a comedian
i started taking her opinions and i
started asking her for questions
and i started asking different about
scenarios and instead of being a hard
head it's like i was telling somebody
there on the phone you could go solo i
was talking to christy belich a dear
comic friend of mine
and i was telling her that you could go
so far
even in music mike is sitting right
across from me
you could go so far in music but at some
point you're going to need help
it may not be the help you want to need
but you're going to need help
they're going to show up help will
arrive
in my situation she did a tape last week
and she was talking about
all she ever wanted was the comedy store
and i called her up and i go
christy and all the years i know you
couldn't pull me aside and go joey
i want a job as a door girl at the store
can you do something for me
for christy belich i wouldn't have done
it in a heart attack because i know
she's a hard worker
look at christie follow christy belichi
on facebook now
she's out every night doing comedy cover
to know coving
then she's reading horoscopes she's
[__] she's a hustler so when you're a
hustler i got your [__] back so i
called and i go why don't you tell me
that you wanted to be a dog girl at the
store i would have got you into the
[__] store
you know it's all these little [__]
things that if
there comes a point in your life that
you're doing great but you're going to
need help
and it comes sometimes in the help of a
woman
and in my case that's what i needed i
have to and
i have on it to admit something to you
guys
without my wife i don't know dick i
don't know how many times a week
somebody will call me
and say joey we need the answers to this
and i go that's great
you don't have to talk to my wife
because i don't know i don't know the
answers to that [__] question i don't
have the answers to that question
so i made my wife my partner and my life
changed
150 i have a life
i have a life because i made her my
partner not my wife
my partner whatever she doesn't
whatever she lacks i'm strong in
and wherever i lack she's [__] strong
so we fit like a glove we fit like
[__] og's glove [__]
you know what i'm saying damn i fit in
there just like
oj's glove and i didn't know this this
is how
weird life is i have been with terry for
20 years
and it's like i told you guys i did not
know
what the gift of marriage was until last
week
until 10 days ago the first time i had
to go in the shower
with my [__] stroller and she had to
sit there and watch me take a [__]
shower
i felt like prison the first time you
take a shower in prison
the guards watch you they [__] watch
you you know how [__] humiliating
that is
for one second i looked over
and i saw her looking at me and she was
looking at me
with eyes of concern that i wouldn't
fall over that i wouldn't slip that i
wouldn't get hurt
and i'll tell you i looked at her and i
go wow
wow as i was [__] shampooing my hair
and shaving
i was thinking about and again i don't
want to sound like that [__]
because it could be anybody
what god has done for us by making
marriage a gift
it's not a [__] sentence man people
think that marriage is a death sentence
when you when i see a guy that's been
married four times
i go jesus christ what did you do did
you not learn did you not get it right
from the
first time i got married right after the
first loss
you know again right there in divorce
court
is where you realize all the things you
didn't do and it's not the big thing
it's
not the trips to hawaii it's not the
diamond rings
it's not the [__] engagements it's
not the the birthday parties with 50 of
your favorite friends
you know it's not the bottle of wine
it's the little things taking out the
garbage
rubbing their feet asking them if you
could help them with the dishes
you know asking them these are little
things
that women appreciate more than anything
in the world
there's times i come in i'm not doing it
i'm like nurse let's get the [__] out of
here my wife was like where are you
taking her
anywhere just to give you a breather you
know friday night i was in pain here
friday night i was in pain you know we
went to physical therapy
on the way back i got cars sick i puked
my wife came back she goes you know what
i'm cancelling my thing tonight with the
guy
what what what are you talking about
what are you talking about well you've
been
in this [__] house all week taking
care of some fat
[__] smelling his balls when you change
his leg
i go go out have a [__] great time
i'll order chinese delivery
whatever the [__] i ordered i didn't end
up ordering anything i just had a salad
upstairs
but i realized what the gift of [__]
marriage was
it's a sacrament for a reason you know
when i was in there and i was watching
her bathe me
i thought about those words in sickness
or in health
look at your girlfriend right now think
about 30 years from now if you get sick
is she the type of woman that's gonna
sit there and take care of you
and watch you and wipe your [__] ass
listen i don't know about you the day
somebody wipes my ass please
just come over and put a rope around my
neck just come over and put a rope
around my neck that's how i've always
thought about it
the day somebody has to wipe my ass i'm
gonna be
because i can never live with something
like that i i have a hard time with
somebody bringing me a water
never mind wipe sticking five fingers up
my ass i'm wiping it
but through sickness and health those
words rang
so [__] hard loud in my heart and my
soul
10 days ago that it made me look at my
wife completely differently
after 20 years you know next time you go
home you know when i was brought up in
[__] i was brought up in [__]
relationships my mother didn't have a
relationship with one
that was a [__] that was a [__]
[__] show
you know but i grew up around people who
really loved each other the benders
the balzanos you know i grew up around
couples that
i've still together today and i looked
at them and i
wondered what made them stay together
and you know what as a man you got to
shut your [__] pile
listen to them listen to what they have
to say to you they have a voice too
hey when i was 20 25 30 i didn't think
this way
at all i thought [__] them you know
cook dinner where's my laundry what a
[__] jerk off i was
especially how i was raised my my
my mom was not that type of woman that
was just going to sit there and lay down
sally and do laundry and take your
[__] orders from me
that was never going to happen so next
time you look at your girlfriend
and you think about life because trust
me something i didn't do
was think about my 50s i never thought
about my 40s i never thought about my
30s
because i was having such a great time
with the [__] drugs
i never thought i would make it that far
but surprise hello
god kept me here and now i'm 58 years
old
i can barely [__] walk i'm getting
better and stronger every day
but i learned the biggest gift of this
one of the biggest gifts of life
is the holy sacrament of [__]
marriage and if you ever get a chance to
do it go in there with a smile on your
face
and be proud that you're [__]
qualified to be a husband
and a father i never thought i would do
this i failed at this 20 years ago
in 1990 i failed at being a father
in 1991 i failed at being a husband
it [__] stuck with me and it burned a
[__] hole in my heart
and here i am today with a daughter with
a wife
who i [__] happily love and i have no
qualms with
i want to die with her i want to die
first because i couldn't let i'm sure if
my wife died
i just have a heart attack at the
[__] funeral i can't live without it
but anyway enough of that morbid death i
just wanted to talk about conor mcgregor
today
and the gift of [__] marriage and how
important it is
and if you ever do it take it [__]
100 seriously
and put 100 commitment into it no
[__]
nothing you know if you when you get
married is because you're ready to get
married
don't get married because my mother
thinks i should get married
if you still want to hang out with your
friends in snort blow then don't get
[__] married don't waste nobody's
time
if you still want to go to your buddy's
house all day sunday
and watch tv with your friends yeah it
doesn't bother your girlfriend
but it's going to bother your wife
because she wants you to spend some time
with her there's all these
different things i'm happy i was man
enough
to push my pride aside some of my man
who decided to make this marriage work
i'm very happy because i could not live
my life with two divorces
that's an automatic [__] death
sentence for me
as a human being as a catholic and as a
man
and that's it for january the 25th
2021 i wish i could have made this
podcast funnier today
but it is what it is funny comes out
when it's supposed to come out
it's not supposed to be forced i'm happy
you're still even watching me
i'm having a great time thank you i'm
having a great time on the patreon
thank you for the messages uh like i
said i'm leaving here
to go do pt and to get the stitches out
i wanted to get this out of the way
first
so i still would have some color in my
face because after they take the
stitches out i think i'm going down
today
but i'll be back wednesday and don't
forget tonight
for draftkings you got nba action you
got college action
we're gonna walk you right through this
i don't want nobody getting into any
[__] gaming problems
or gambling debts we're going to do this
the right way
small amounts every week we get better
and better
i want to thank you for watching uncle
joey's joint
i want to thank you for watching uh for
being on patreon
three five and ten dollars i'm gonna put
a merch
uh line up pretty soon
for hoodies short shirt short sleeve
t-shirts
and the junky t-shirt the one i like i
like long sleeve
just in case you're a junkie you're
hiding some or you want to put a knife
in there
or a straw to shoot bb guns whatever the
[__] you're into
that's why i like the long sleeve shirts
but anyway it's monday the 25th of
january i love you guys
thank you for watching we'll be back
wednesday [__]
and if you want to listen to a short
podcast tomorrow the joey diaz project
will be on patreon like i told you three
five
and ten dollars if you can't get enough
of me me i can't get enough of me either
that's why i'm getting the [__] out of
here i love you guys thank you very much
for watching to join
see you wednesday morning stay black
all right i want to thank you
[__] for listening today it's
monday morning i like to get you in and
out of there
so there's no drama let's start with the
[__] basics
uncle joey's joint is brought to you by
honor.com why on it
because they're the best anybody who
gives you a product and tells you if you
don't like it
you could don't have to send it back and
they'll send you the money back
that tells me your character that tells
me that you believe in your [__]
product how many people do that nobody
you ever go to your drug deal oh this
weed sucks i want my money back too bad
you smoke the joint [__] it you broke it
you pay for it not on it
they play by the [__] rules and if
they do that with their flagship i can't
imagine
they got the melatonin they got the
shroom tech they got the new mood the
shrimp tech is tremendous
whether it's the immune or the sport
they're both [__] tremendous
now they got the protein powered puffs
another thing that's tremendous
korean barbecue flavored and spicy
cheddar let me tell you something
these [__] things this little bag has
15 grams of protein
that's two [__] eggs you understand
me right here
protein powder puffs korean barbecue and
they taste great
tremendous little snacks in between go
to honor.com right now
and press in church and get 10
off delivered right to your
[__] house addict
is the way to go the joint is also
brought to you by
c b d lion why
joey because i don't want you going to a
[__] bodega
and buying some [__] cbd from some
guy
that don't even know how to get to
[__] connecticut that's why is that
good enough for you
this guy can't shoot bubble gum and walk
at the [__] same time
and you're trusting your life in his
hands ah what you're gonna do is you're
gonna go to cbdline.com right now
read read read knowledge
is power iacocca read learn about what
the [__] is going on here with cbd
and how it could affect you whether you
have arthritis whether you have anxiety
whether you have neck pain if you have
an ailment
cbd lion has a cure go to the cbd line
whether it's the gummies the roland the
bat
the back balls the vapor pen the cbd
kinesiology tape which i've been using
also on the sides
i don't even have but my leg isn't even
purple no more i mean that
this thing has done miracles with the
surgery i want to tip my hat i even
reached out to andrew
at cbd line and told them now i really
really see the effects
of cbd line and how they work since i
had the surgery
go to cbdlion right now.com
read the third party lab results press
in church or joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
[__] house the best cbd products
on the market from your uncle joey i'm
not [__] kidding around
go to cbd lion right now now you know me
dog i'm just like you [__]
i like to make a little [__]
money on the side but
you got to be smart about it especially
when it comes to gambling
and especially when it comes to
draftkings because they they give you
a thousand and one different ways to
make a [__] dollar
whether it's sports betting the poker
rooms the odd boosts
they got it all parlays [__]
specialists i mean they ran a special
saturday
mcgregor a dollar you get 257 dollars
back mcgregor came close
but what did you have to lose for a
dollar to win 257
that's why i do business with draftkings
i love everything about them
and this the season to be [__] jolly
right here then listen for something
like kids get
kids little dicks get hard in december
santa claus is coming well it's january
[__] and draftkings is [__] showing
up
with the golden tickets the moment we've
all been waiting for the season is right
around the corner
draftking is the official partner of
super bowl 55
is bringing back their golden ticket
giveaway with up to 55 million
dollars in prizes that's 55 million
bucks
with your name on each one of them could
you imagine what you do with a million
dollars right now
go to portugal eat an octopus get your
dick sucked
these are the advantages of getting a
million dollars you want to get in on
the action
all you got to do is enter draftkings
free
super bowl prediction challenge and
here's the best part they're going to
give you a chance to instantly win
as soon as you submit your picks up to
20 thousand bucks
that's a lot of [__] getus and if
you're right you get a chance to win
one million dollars guys you've been
reading tea leaves all your
[__] year and looking into a crystal
ball getting your mojo in order to shoot
your
shot well now is the time to get it
bet on yourself but the best part of
this the whole challenge
is absolutely free to enter just
download the app that's it download the
[__] draftkings sportsbook app it's
highly rated
download it and enter the free
prediction challenge and answer a few
simple questions
that you already know the answer to who
will score last
you know who and boom there you go
you're [__] at a cash register
getting 20 spit out on you since 2012
draftking has paid over seven billion
dollars
your big payday is around the corner in
other words
your ship is coming in but you gotta
play the [__] wind
so go to draftkings.com right now
download the app
and enter the free 55 million dollar
super bowl prediction challenge
everybody gets an innocent prize up to
25 thousand dollars
just the [__] plan use promo code
joey
now enter the free 55 million dollar
super bowl challenge
only at draftkings the official daily
fantasy partner
of super bowl 55 terms conditions
and eligibility restrictions apply see
draftkings.com
for details don't forget to download the
app right now as we speak
and press code joey to enter the 55
million dollar challenge
i love you [__] have a great
monday
and i'll see you wednesday all right i'm
over here waiting for the [__] snow
like an eskimo
stay black
so
you